[Musique]
tout comme le drapeau du mexique il
existe trois couleurs de peau sur les
vers blancs et rouges moi j'ai fait un
beau soleil och donc ça prend ça pour
donner la couleur et la saveur
du piment évidemment nous sommes chez
pilar qui habite dans une banlieue à
4600 kilomètres de mexico pour ça je n'y
vois cision oui c'est un film un peu
forte patron c'est un plat très
traditionnelle qu'on fait souvent à la
fête dans l'excès qui est le 15
septembre
entre une soupe et un ragoût ne pose sur
les composés à la base d'un bouillon de
viande et de maïs mais pas n'importe
lequel la bd c'est vraiment les maïs
blanc c'est ça qui donne les cours
particuliers à l'assaut ce maïs le
cacahuètes inkley est une variété avec
des grains blancs plutôt coriace c'est
maïs est vraiment cultivé au mexique
dont l ego vraiment cette un goût très
particulière si on la compare avec
l'émail est ici au québec quand c'est
sexy dans l'ailé ou de la soupe mais
s'impose la terre du mexique temps qui
tanguent aux différentes au maïs
les grains de maïs doivent être bouillie
dans une solution alcaline un mélange
d'eau et de chaux ou de cendres de bois
afin d'éliminer la membrane fibreuse ce
qui va le rendre beaucoup plus tendre
n'ayez crainte pas besoin de sortir la
chaux ou la cendre dans les épiceries
mexicaine et d'amérique latine on trouve
ce maïs en conserve prêtes à être
utilisées
en fait donc bien dosé m'étais maïs
blanc dans une casserole avec des lots
donc on va le laisser bouillir pendant
deux heures ouais geyrhalter d'eline
deslauriers décoiffe et douce et ça
c'est la base oui 500 cas pas de pot sol
et
pilar laisse mijoter 2 heures puis
ajoute la viande directement dans le
bouillon il ya des personnes qui vont
doubler ou du porc mais moi j'ai trop ce
qu'elle les mélanges t'es d'où vient sa
dont saragosse las avortée de l'assaut
sont vraiment laisser cuire longtemps
comme ça la viande va absorber tous les
goûts du maïs
les tomates des oignons des piments qui
ajoute couleurs mais aussi saveurs et
odeurs
[Musique]
à montréal la chef et l'émir réalise un
rêve et cuisine la recette familiale de
popoli dans son restaurant le cas la
violence qu'est ce que ça veut dire le
nom du restaurant qu'elle avait des
morts
partout toxiques au lieu des différentes
dépenses aux lions n'allaient pas sur
les blanches aulas les poteaux les verts
ont réalisé
des fraudes ben pour moi mon préféré
c'est les rouches qu'est ce qui fait
qu'ils aient vous jouiez 20 vouliez
blain ces collectifs les tills les rues
sont les faits avec newcastle c'est le
climat qu'ils vont faire avec les
piments qui est qu'elle est qu'elle va
faire l'écho l'eau rouge le blanc c'est
la même chose sans les paiements
pourrait pousser les verts qu'on l'aimé
des laits l'intérieur des
des citrouilles à huis
clos son cd tomatillos que celles
de tomates au pdci linteau et tous les
maîtres haussier des verts
si la base est primordial pour sa
réussite un bon pour ceux qui viennent
avec beaucoup de garnitures laitue h et
radis oignons line coriandre salsa
ses fruits ou ce hoquet
souvent cas comme dans bien des pays la
recette des limites et transmises de
génération en génération
chaque fois
les pouvoirs des jeunes et des dîners
des super beau soleil
que se situe la baie beaucoup de piquant
si tous les soirs et dur après tout
machin avait beaucoup de répit quand
donc c'est la recette de ta mère la g
moi ma
[Musique]
famille aussi
pour les banques ont fini